as I know that will afford you pleasure
that I have brought my odds taking to a
successful result I have determined to
write to you this letter to inform you
of everything that has been done and
discovered in this voyage of mine on the
33rd day after leaving Cadiz I came into
the Indian sea where I discovered many
islands inhabited by numerous peoples I
took possession of all of them for our
most fortunate King by making public
Proclamation on furling his standard no
one making any resistance to the first
of them I have given the name of our
blessed Savior trusting in whose aid
that I had reached this and all the rest
but the Indians called it Gua Nahanni to
each of the others I also gave a new
name ordering one to be called sancta
maria to concepción another Fernandina
another isabella and another johanna and
so with all the rest as soon as we
reached the island which i have just
said was called joanna i sailed along
its coast some considerable distance
towards the west and found it to be so
large without any apparent end that i
believed it was not an island but a but
a continent a province of Cathay but I
saw neither towns nor cities lying on
the seaboard only some villages and
country farms with whose inhabitants I
could not get speech because they fled
as soon as they beheld us I continued on
supposing I should come upon some city
or country houses at last finding that
no discoveries rewarded our further
progress and that this course was
leading us toward the north which I was
desirous of avoiding as it was winter in
these regions and it had always been my
intention to proceed southwards and the
winds were also favourable to such
desires I concluded not to attempt any
other adventures so turning back
I came again to a certain harbour which
I had remark
from the error sent two of our men into
the country to learn whether there was
any King or cities in that land they
journeyed for three days and found
innumerable people and habitations but
small and having no fixed government on
which account they returned meanwhile I
had learned from some Indians whom I had
seized at this place that the country
was was really an island consequently I
continued along towards the east as much
as 322 miles always hugging the shore
where was the very extremity of the
island from there I saw another Island
to the eastwards distant 54 miles from
Miss Joanna which I named Hispanic and
proceeded to it and directed my course
for five hundred sixty four miles east
by north as it were just as I had done
at Joanna the island called Joanna's as
well as the others in its neighborhood
is exceedingly fertile there's numerous
harbors and all sides very safe and wide
above comparison with anything I've ever
seen through it flow very many broad and
health-giving rivers and there any
numerous very lofty mountains all these
islands are very beautiful easy to be
traversed and full of the greatest
variety of trees reaching to the stars
I think these never lose their leaves as
I saw them looking as green and lovely
as they all want to be in the month of
May in Spain some of them were in leaf
and some in fruit each flourishing in
the condition its nature required the
nightingale was singing it in various
other little birds when I was rambling
among them in the month of November
they're also in the island called
Johanna seven or eight kinds of palms
which is readily surpassed ours in
height and beauty as to all the other
trees herbs and fruits
there are also wonderful pine woods
fields and extensive meadows birds of
various kinds and honey and all the
different metals they accept iron
in the island which I've said before was
called hispana there are many lofty and
beautiful mountains great farms groves
and fields most fertile both for
cultivation and for pasturage and well
adapted for constructing buildings the
convenience of the harbours in this
island and the excellent of the rivers
in volume and celebrity surpass human
belief unless one should see them in it
the trees pasture lands and fruits
differ much from those of Joanna besides
this is spanner abounds in various kinds
of spices gold and metals the
inhabitants of both sexes of this and
all of the other islands I have seen or
of which I have any knowledge always go
as naked as they came into this world
except that some of the women cover
their private parts with with leaves or
branches or or a veil of cotton which
they prepare themselves for this purpose
they are all as I said before unprovided
with any sort of iron and they are
destitute of arms which are entirely
unknown to them and for which they are
not adapted not on account of any bodily
deformity for they are well made but
because they are timid and full of
terror they carry however canes dried in
the Sun in place of weapons upon whose
roots they fix her wooden shaft dried
and sharpened to a point but they never
dare to make use of these for his often
happened when I'm when I've sent two or
three of my men to some of their
villages to speak with the inhabitants
the the crowd of Indians of sallied
forth but when they saw our men
approaching they speedily took flight
parents abandon their children and
children their parents this happened not
because of any loss or injury had been
inflicted on any of them are on the
contrary I gave whatever I had class and
many other things to whomsoever I
approach
with whom I could get speech without any
return being made to me but they are by
nature fearful and timid but when they
see that they are safe and all fear is
banished
they are very guileless and honest a
very liberal of all they have no one
refuses the Oscar anything that he
possesses are on the contrary they
themselves invite us to ask for it they
manifest the greatest affection towards
all of us exchanging valuable things for
trifles content with the very least
thing or nothing at all but i forbade
giving them very trifling thing and of
no value such as bits of plates dishes
and glass also nails and straps although
it seemed to them if they could get such
that they are quite the most beautiful
jewels in the world for chanced that a
sailor received for single strap as much
weight of gold as three gold Sallee D
and so others for things unless price
especially for new blankets of some gold
coins which they gave whatever the
seller asked for instance and ounce and
a half or two ounces of gold or thirty
or forty pounds of cotton with which
they are already familiar so to fit four
pieces are hoops jugs jars and pots they
bartered cotton and gold like beasts the
this i forbade because it was plainly
unjust and they gave them many beautiful
and pleasing things which I brought with
me for no return whatsoever in order to
win their affection and that they might
become Christians and inclined to love
out king and queen and princes and all
the people of Spain and that they might
be eager to search for and gather and
give to us what they are bound in and we
greatly need
they do not practice idolatry on the
contrary they believe that all strength
all power in short all blessings are
from heaven and that I've come down from
there with these ships and sailors and
in this spirit was I received everywhere
after they had got over their fear they
are neither lazy nor awkward but on the
contrary are of an excellent and acute
understanding those who have sailed
these seas get excellent accounts of
everything but they have never seen men
wearing clothes or more ships like ours
as soon as I had come into this sea I
took by force some Indians from the
first island in order that they might
learn from us and at the same time tell
us what they knew about affairs in these
regions
this succeeded admirably for in a short
time we understood them and they us both
by gesture and signs and words and they
were of great service to us they're
coming now with me and I've always
believed that I have come from heaven
notwithstanding a long time they have
been and still remain with us they were
the first who told this wherever we went
one calling to another with a loud voice
come come you will see men from heaven
upon both women and men children and
adults young and old laying aside the
fear they had felt before
[ __ ] eagerly to see us a great crowd
thronging about our steps some bringing
food and others drink with greatest love
an incredible goodwill in each Island
are many boats made of solid wood though
narrow yet in length and shaped similar
to our two bankers but swifter in motion
and managed by oars only some of them
are large some small and some of the
medium-sized but most are larger than a
- banker rowed by 18 oars with these
they sail to all of the islands which
are innumerable engaging in traffic and
commerce with each other I saw some of
these boats which carried 70 or 80
rowers in all these islands there is no
difference in the appearance of the
inhabitants so none of their customs and
language so that all understand one
another this is a circumstance most
favourable for what I believe our most
serene King especially desires that is
their conversion to the holy faith of
Christ which indeed as far as I can
understand they are ready and prune I've
told already how I sailed in a straight
course along the island of Johanna from
west to east 322 miles from this voyage
and the extent of my journeys I can say
that this Joe
is larger than England and Scotland
together for beyond the aforesaid 322
miles in that portion which looks
towards the West there are two more
provinces but which I did not visit one
of them the Indians called anon had its
inhabitants er born with tails these
provinces extend 180 miles as I learned
from the Indians whom I am bringing with
me and who are well-acquainted with all
these islands the distance around his
spanner is greater than all Spain from
Colonia to font Arabia as is readily
proved because its fourth side which I
myself traversed in a straight course
from West East stretched 540 miles this
island is to be coveted and not to be
despised to and acquired as I've already
taken possession of all the others as I
have said for almost invincible King and
the rule over them is entirely committed
to the said king so in this one I have
taken special possession over a certain
larger town in the most convenient spot
well-suited for all profit and commerce
to which I've given the name of the
Nativity of our Lord and there I ordered
a fort to be built forthwith which ought
to be finished now in it I left as many
men as seemed necessary with all kinds
of arms and provisions sufficient for
more than a year also a care avala and
men to build others skilled not only in
this trade but in others I support for
them the goodwill and remarkable
friendship of the king of the island for
these people are very affectionate and
kind so much so that the aforesaid King
took a pride in my being called his
brother
although shrewd they changed their minds
and wished to harm those who have
remained in the fort they cannot because
well they huh without arms go naked and
are too timid so that in truth those who
hold the aforesaid fort can lay waste to
the whole of the island without any
danger to themselves provided they do
not violate the rules and instructions I
have given them
in all these islands as I understand
every man is satisfied with only one
life except the princes or Kings who are
permitted to have 20 the women appear to
work more than the men but I could not
well understand whether they have
private property or not if I saw that
what everyone had was shared with the
others especially meals provisions in
men and such things I found among them
no monsters as many expected but men of
great deference and kind nor are they
black like the Ethiopians but they have
long straight hair they do not dwell
where the Rays of the sun's of most
power although the sun's heat is very
great there as this region is 26 degrees
distant from the equatorial line from
the summit's of the mountains there
comes great cold but the Indians
mitigated by being inured to the weather
and by the help of very hot food which
they consume frequently and in a
moderate quantities
I saw no monsters neither did I have
accounts of any such except in an island
called charas ii as one crosses over
from spain to india which is inhabited
by a certain race regarded by their
neighbors as very ferocious they eat
human flesh and make use of several
kinds of boats which they cross over to
all the indian islands and plunder and
carry off whatever they can but they
differ in no respect from the others
except in wearing their hair long after
the fashion of women they make use of
bows and arrows made of reeds having
pointed shafts fastened to the thicker
portion as we have before described for
this reason they are considered to be
ferocious and the other Indians
consequently are terribly afraid of them
they have intercourse with certain women
who dwell lone upon the island of
michurin the first as one crosses from
Spain to India these women follow none
of the usual occupations of their sex
but they use bows and arrows like those
of their husbands which I have described
and protect themselves with plates of
copper which is found in the greatest
abundance among them I was informed that
there is another island larger than the
aforesaid hispana whose inhabitants have
no hair and that there is greater
abundance of gold in it than in the
others some of the inhabitants of these
islands and of the others i have seen i
am bringing over with me to bear
testimony to what i've reported finally
to sum up in a few words the chief
results and advantage of our departure
and speedy return i make this promise to
almost invincible sovereign that if i am
supported by some little assistance from
them I will give them as much gold as
they have need of and in addition spices
cotton and mastic which is found only in
chios and as many heathen slaves as
their Majesty may choose to demand
besides these rhubarb and other kinds of
drugs which I think the men left in the
fort before alluded to have already
discovered or will do so as I myself
have delayed nowhere longer than the
winds compelled me except when I was
provided for the construction of a fort
in the city of Nativity and for making
all things safe although these matters
are very wonderful and unheard-of there
would have been more so if ships of a
reasonable account had been furnished me
board has been accomplished is great and
wonderful and not at all proportionate
to my desserts but to the sacred
Christian faith and to the piety and
religion of our sovereign for the mind
of a man could not compass the Spirit of
God has granted to mortals for God is
wont to listen to his servants who love
his precepts even in impossibilities as
has happened to me in the present
instance who has accomplished what human
strength has hit whom never attained for
if anyone has written or told anything
about these islands all have done so
either obscurely or by guesswork so this
has almost seemed to be fabulous
therefore let king and queen and princes
and their most fortunate realms and all
other Christian provinces that has all
returned thanks to our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ who was bestowed so great a
victory and reward upon us
let there be processions and solemn
sacrifices prepared that the churches
bedecked with festal boughs that Christ
rejoice upon earth as he rejoices in
heaven as he foresees that so many souls
of so many people here to fall lost are
to be saved and let us be glad not only
for the exaltation of our faith but also
for the increase of temporal prosperity
in which not only Spain but all
Christendom is about to share as these
things have been accomplished so have
they been briefly narrated farewell
Christopher : Admiral of the ocean fleet
Lisbon
March 14th